le département andin justice a validé le
fait de réexaminer un certain nombre de
documents issus des enquêtes autour des
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 le fbi va
devoir désormais se pencher sur à
quelles informations sont susceptibles
d'être dévoilée au grand public une
décision qui a été saluée par le
président américain joe biden qui
réclamaient plus de transparence et qui
était la cible de critiques de la part
de familles de victimes du 11 septembre
elle avait signé la semaine passée une
lettre ouverte à destination du
président américain signé par 1700
personnes voici un extrait
nous comprenons le souhait du président
byden de marquer l'occasion du 20e
anniversaire à ground zero cependant
nous ne pouvons pas de bonne foi et avec
considération pour les disparus les
malades et les blessés accueillir le
président avant qu'il n'ait compléter
ses engagements un moyen pour ces les
associations de familles de victimes de
faire pression sur les autorités pour
avoir gain de cause eux qui se bat
depuis des années pour obtenir la vérité
sur ce qu'il s'est réellement passé
autour de ces attentats il accuse
notamment un certain nombre de pays
notamment l'arabie saoudite d'avoir fait
preuve de complicité dans le fait
d'avoir organisé ces attaques contre les
tours jumelles ainsi que sur le
pentagone ces familles de victimes se
sont montrées plutôt sceptique suite à
ces annonces du département de justice
américain ils attendent des actes
concrets et puis surtout on ne sait pas
réellement quelles informations sont
susceptibles d'être rendue publique par
les autorités compétentes ces prochaines
semaines alors que évidemment le mois de
septembre prochain marquera le 20e
anniversaire de ces attentats du 11
septembre 2001 une cérémonie devrait
être organisée à new york et en présence
évidemment du président joe biden